I like to ince Our Next speer Jord
smth Jody is a ma Lear enine he work
Here In
amst he likes to work at Inter bwe softw
Engineering and dat Science and Today He
has a n Talk for us about apparent How
chat gpt got Access To His St  l me he
gave it to chat gpt and so R of pleas
for
J
Thank
you this Talk is Indeed about How I gave
gpt Access to my to list Before I Go
into that First bit about me machine
Learning
engineer h i help companies build
machine Learning Solutions  and data
other data Solutions ranging from data
Products or data platforms Whatever
People companies want to do data and in
free Time Indeed I love to work at Ai
and machine Learning related Side
Projects So This Year has been
especially cool with the release of CH
gpt and  all the other API stuff that has
been released but This is also a Bit of
My Own downfall Because I love to add a
lot of Things to my to-do list I don't
know if other people do this as well but
I tend to  do add Everything I read
online to an inbox and it Keeps on
Growing Growing and Growing and it
Becomes way too large and usually
do Tos
Help
my
May logical
grings ex
grings Different Projects Maybe even
create Them Move the tasks Over There
and make the Cleaning part  at least a
bit faster and Less tedious for Myself
To Do It was the goal I set Out To Do of
course I Ask J gpt to do it but It
Doesn't know my to do list So you get
These default answers I don't  have
Access to that personal information like
All The Other Safety stuff Open A
typically gives
you well of course I can copy paste It
into there
Yes we software Engineers we don't like
to do this I'm Want To Be bit more Lazy
that luckily  There all these There are
all these Kind of API to do is the tool
I use for my to do list has a really
nice API that can give you all your
Projects task That are there and Easily
gives you Them even has a nice Python
sdk to  use There open Ai has a nice
API we can Just with Lines we can
already Do
Time we Not There yet are ex
resp quite
forming Natural language is that There are
many differents to write the same
Thing Do Is How can we This Is example
Getting Finding grins  I May Want To Let
it move My task create new Projects or
let LM make a plan to accomplish a bit
more obstructive task I have for it uh
Before we Dive into that we need to know
Bit of background of How These lms work
like chat gpt  is Just A Very Fancy aete
to has been Train
aete That's on There bit more Fancy Ok
lot More
Fancy after
that they did One additional step is
that they Fun it to respond in a
conversational
St Get Like
user
is instruction
system It has been f Tuned  to Follow
These instructions so we can already we
can Change These instructions a bit Here
example we it to Follow response In More
Of Jon like format It will try to Follow
these instructions As Long As it Kind of
understand what you're saying There And
then  you can see this Kind of Jon like
resp is already quite a bit Nicer we
want to
Python
ok we do
API is Bit of Clever prp injecting
additional information how do we
actually get to autonomous agent This Is
Just giving me an answer of How to
Easily  see grouping and Which belongs
Where but I want to do have it do More
like Create a new project move a task
for my inbox to that project and other
Clever stuff That makes My bit
easier ex
May please
moox Pro new Pro
It it something like of  course I'm on it
in the background It Ask for the bag in
my inbox get a nice list Over There
based on that response The API it Should
make a request of all the existing Pro
is
there May
And then The API ok successful move all
the tasks to that specific project Over
There And then It's done
ands small summary of what it actually
Did The
Ideal Way we Wanted To Act how do We Go
from that chat format to this
format to do that There are Clever
People that came up with this  React
framework This Is A Way uh basically A
Very Smart system prompt that tells It
How to respond so what it does Here is
First It has to respond with a thought
that it can do a bit of reasoning and
and write what it's Thinking What should
be  Done Make Some Kind of plan Over
There eh so for example I don't know the
tasks yet so I need to get all the tasks
from the inbox then it Should write the
action It Wants To Do based on its
current plan so for example get  all the
observation observation this case is
resp the API part is generated LM this
part is the to API write Out in Jon
format t
Whats
GT
end I Know The
Final The Final answer The response i a
human
Again how do this
Look prev
example we would get  Something like this
please move all my tasks in my inbox
into a project create project
needed things ok need to get
pending prev
observation
is general
backgrounds in
Dem h we stream version application on
the left s
example
ino Middle instruction I'm to it
instruction
are  get all the task in the inbox Try
toid related tasks think of suitable
project name for These groups If not If
not such a project create project then move
All tasks to project and ensure the
inbox is empty afterwards
let all the tasks all the inbox tasks
Gets  a big json
list based on that it is has identified
the birthday Celebration project Should
Be
created It has been
added via the rest
API it now notice specific task
that needs to be moved There like the
This one Above has been moved Over There
and it  Keeps Now itera on that part
slowly ming Over
There ites me Fin answer that has mov
Everything I also really is that really
took The instruction verifi Inox empty
observation There is
empty
inbox work Follow The instructions Very
carefully Made The plan on How to do it
entirely  by
pretty
cool Okay So This is how the final
results actually work to get there is
quite a bit tricky discuss the general
framework
There specific implementation details
make it a bit more
tricky for example The initial System
prompt I Had to design to do that is bit
more lengthy As you can see First I need
to tell it
about the general
context to l AG Following I'm using The
getting things done framework typically
for my to do l Lot of information about
loop description Pretty much sim we h
the most tricky part  is description of
all the tools and actions It can do
Just
making you get into tricky water and May
enter the domain of part we want to AV
that because It will quickly crash
bur even very
ly
ex
PR
mistakes The Mo
Action decided to make Slightly
Different  format
or do other things that make it really
hard to this because now the project ID
is one Times called project ide The
Other Times project and differences make
it very hard
to the solution I that works
is to actually define ptic model ptic is
a nice library  that allows you to
define data Models and All Kinds Of
additional information about What is
this specific attribute nice
descriptions other validation things
like regular
expressions and the real thing I
really likes About This is that it also
has a Method called schema and Th you
can automatically  export It
J How I want the response of the action
ism are
lar Corpus of code efficient reading cod
This is more expressive than me trying
to do exp all this in Natural
language developer i canine Action
schema can read it Bas on Jon
schema nice Thing about  that is that
your available actions Becomes quite bit
Shorter at least the part
I general TM is still on in l the part I
is Shorter I can in schema Over There
rem a lot of Spaces
Nice
[Music]
h
is had moot of
tas Kind of  de to
I My plan is Mo Over There that Action
that Action
exist
so then I decided Ok schemas work well
Maybe take it even One level further
Let's let llm Only respond in Jason
Follow this entire response so The
previous React framework We were talking
about Let's  Just encode that in one
Giant identical model in this React
response model now we also have encoded
the t Here So It Needs It's Now Always
need to respond with a Jason object that
has a t attribute And then It Can Only
respond with an Action that is defined
about here so then you get the response
like you see Here on the right Side
thought I need to and an action with the
specific type and all the attributes
that Need To Be There Works Rather well
so other nice part my work Becomes even
More Shorter I  Don't Need To Explain The
React framework anymore because it's
already Being generated there
automatically
I of general instructions are And that
it Only is allowed to respond in Jon
using this specific schema My promt
Becomes Shorter at Le the part I need wr
other thing also  nice is that it works
really well with the new matching
keyboard Python 3.10 I can The response
schema and check If one of specific
model
acing mistakes
ex
of make mistakes actually write Good
error messages Good exceptions And if
you actually the previous Match
statement If You wrap  that in Thing in a
Try Catch Block and replace The
observation with your error message from
your Exception and Give that Back to the
LM It actually could quite often fix it
Own Mistake As long as you tell what the
Mistake was Maybe Give a suggestion ok
there  is no project ide with that so use
this Action that Maybe has the proper
information and That Way quite Often
could fix it Own Mistake is quite
interesting to
see One Thing that was
special One Time was update open Ai
and They released a new retrain model
and  This one was a bit more aptic than
the previous one We probably all saw
It oh my apologies I can't answer that
even made a Mistake in the Jason schema
then It Still responded with the proper
Jason schema but it Made some apologies
before and Before  because It Didn't Do
It So What do you do with this Kind of
Things You Throw More Ai at the Problem
You What I did is that I have the
original base schema need to Ad here to
and I asked another llm to say van  Okay
I have got this response It needs to
Follow here to this schema and I Have
This Exception and pid dentic it's
really Nice has quite Clear exceptions
already so I Don't I didn't even need to
write Those exceptions yet I Give that
an  error message and I let it
iterate at most three times and it would
always Fix It the first time Maybe it
got It Wrong the second Time would
always fix it and the nice Thing is if
you replace in the previous response
with that with the new correct  response
you build that Up In Your History is
that you are basically generating few
shot examples And then For Your First
For Your First Action It Sometimes makes
this Mistake but Because you generate
few uh few short examples It Becomes Way
harder for the model to actually deviate
from
that so what are the Lessons learned For
Me during This project the first one is
that code is Way more expressive and
strict than Natural languages ​​lms are
really good at understanding this So if
you can't really If You Find Yourself
writing really hard prompts
jive can
even PS in there gooding things can be
more explicit than The HS of L of t exp
It other thing is that must be extremely
Clear in your description that was one
of the tricky Parts is that If You are
ambiguous in your Question ofas you
Wanted to do
is that it starts guessing What actually
meant originally I tri to work Clear My
inbox that was bit to abstract it I need
to be bit more Clear on What actually Do
I mean Do I want to do eventually wr
Kind of instructions Figure Out  plan How
to do the
Api
clears was surprising me was that lms
surprisingly well at fixing Their Own
issues is example I was prev talking
about seeing
that trying to Create a project that
doesn't ex already exist And then Oh I
need to accomplish task I  don't need
know the ID It the get project Action
get the
final idea in
s
iser
sanding it works All quite well du to
those ambiguous what you actually Mean I'm
not if I'm quite Ready to give it delete
Action yet so  Moving tasks is fine but I
still want to recover if it
goes
thats
If interested in the codes It's open
source Repo en ja Any questions I'm
happy to
answer